[MUSICAL INTRO]
LOUIS HYMAN: Thank you so
much for having me here today.
And thank you, Rachel,
Professor, Dr. Rachel,
Professor Hyman.
And as a professor, I'm here to
remind you of lessons that you
may have learned long ago.
When we learn about the
Industrial Revolution
in school, we hear a lot about
factories, and steam engines,
and maybe if you had a really
particularly terrible teacher,
the power loom.
And we are taught that this
technological innovation
drives social change,
explains how the world works,
and has made it possible to
work in the way that we do.
Now likewise, when we talk
about today's economy,
we focus on smartphones,
artificial intelligence, apps.
And here too, the inexorable
march of technology
is thought to be
responsible for disrupting
traditional work, for
phasing out the employee who
works for a regular
wage or a salary,
and phasing in independent
contractors, consultants,
temps, and freelancers--
of course, none of
whom are at Google--
the so-called gig economy.
But this narrative is wrong.
This narrative is wrong.
The history of labor shows that
technology does not usually
drive social change.
On the contrary, social
change is driven by decisions
about reorganizing people
that reorganize our work.
Only later does technology
swoop in, accelerate,
and consolidate those changes.
This insight that it's not
just technological determinism,
that it's not just
market determinism is
crucial for anyone who
wants to understand
the insecurity and other
shortcomings of the gig
economy, and more broadly,
our economy today.
Ford reminds us
that, far from being
the unavoidable consequence of
progress, the nature of work
is part of our social
fabric that progress,
technological or otherwise,
does not require insecurity.
Consider the
Industrial Revolution.
Well, before it took
place in the 19th century,
another revolution
in work took place
in the 18th century, which
historians call the Industrious
Revolution.
Before this revolution,
people worked where they
lived, on a farm, or in a shop.
The manufacturing of
textiles, for instance,
relied on networks of
independent farmers
who spun and wove cloth.
They worked on their own.
They were not employees.
In the Industrious
Revolution, manufacturers
gathered workers under one
roof where the work could
be divided and supervised.
For the first time on a large
scale, home life and work life
were separated.
And so this was a precondition
for the Industrial Revolution.
While factory technology would
consolidate this development,
the creation of
factory technology
was only possible because people
were already in the factories.
Solving for this
world, a power loom
would have no purpose if people
still worked in their houses.
And the story continues today
in what I call, in the book,
the Second Industrious
Revolution,
today's digital
revolution in the world,
in the economy that has come
into being since the 1970s.
It's often described as
a second Machine Age.
But it's more like a second
Industrious Revolution that's
been underway for at least
40 years, encompassing
the collapse, since the 1970s,
of the relatively secure work
of the post-war period.
This is the
post-industrialization.
This is the rise of
the service economy.
And over these
four decades, we've
seen an increase in the use
of day laborers, office temps,
management consultants, contract
assemblers, adjunct professors,
Blackwater mercenaries, and
every other kind of person
filing IRS form 1099.
These jobs span
the income ranks.
But what they share in common
is what all work increasingly
seems to have in common
since the 1970s--
insecurity.
This is possible because
of the way in which work
has become to be organized.
Workers are no longer as closely
bound to employers for good
and for bad.
And all the tech
of the gig economy,
all the apps of your smartphone
is the result of that.
For some, the rise
of the gig economy
represents liberation from the
stifling bureaucratic world
of corporate America.
High-paid consultants, well-paid
independent contractors--
it is a return to the autonomy
and independence of an economy
before wage labor--
no desk, no boss,
every consultant
his or her own master.
Yet for the majority of
workers, this so-called freedom
of the gig economy is just
the freedom to be afraid.
It is a severing of obligations
between firms and employers.
[INAUDIBLE] is the
collapse of protections
the people of the United
States, and our laws,
and our customs once
fought hard to enshrine.
Internet technologies
have certainly
intensified this development,
even though most freelancers
remain offline.
But services like Uber and
online freelance markets
like TaskRabbit or
Upwork were created
to take advantage of an
already independent workforce.
They are not creating it.
The technology is solving
the business and consumer
problems of an already
insecure world of work.
Uber is the symptom,
not the cause.
Uber is the waste product
of the service economy.
So today I would like to talk
about just one small part
of this book, which tells the
story of how Americans created
security in the years coming
out of the Great Depression
and World War II
and then suddenly,
unexpectedly dismantled it.
This larger history is
about how the corporation
and the workplace have
changed since the 1930s.
It is a story of
who counts and who
doesn't count, who is
included and who is excluded,
how workplace stability,
how a secure job stopped
being something to be
celebrated and instead
became a problem to be
solved by consultants.
The story I'm
telling today is part
of the story of
Silicon Valley, which
I explore in depth in the book.
This story here is
about temp workers,
and undocumented migrants,
and legal migrants
at the very bottom
of the Silicon Valley
world, the world that's often
not discussed when we read
those biographies of
Steve Jobs, or the Woz,
or all of these other so-called
leaders of Silicon Valley.
So today I'd like to tell
you a different story
of a place with which you're
probably already familiar.
So just as the
agricultural economy
was born between two
great rivers, the Tigris
and Euphrates, so is
the digital economy
born between two great
highways, 101 and 280--
or if you're from Southern
California, the 111
and the 280.
So connecting San
Jose to San Francisco,
these highways define the
eastern and western borders
of Silicon Valley, which
had, until the 1950s, mostly
been fruit trees.
In the 1960s, as the
electronics industry grew,
these trees were
cut down to make way
for factories and offices.
Now today's Silicon Valley
is mostly known for its apps.
But in the '70s and '80s, it was
still a place where products--
first transistors,
and then whole chips--
were made.
And by the 1980s, electronics
was the largest manufacturing
industry in the United States.
It was what economists call the
leading sector, the place that
was driving change,
driving profits.
And Silicon Valley's factories
left Detroit's far behind.
The 1980s-- Detroit
falters, San Jose thrives.
Japan might have
made better cars,
but we made better computers.
And if American manufacturing
was to be successful,
if America still had
a claim on the future,
if America was still seen
as a leader in progress,
it was in Silicon Valley.
The electronics industry
validated new ways
to think about
capitalism since it,
unlike any previous
leading sector, depended
on short-term,
flexible workforces,
depended on venture
capital, depended
on new lean ways
of manufacturing,
new kinds of supply
chains, new kinds
of subcontracted workforces in
a way that Detroit never had.
Unions were nowhere to be found.
And the sporadic
organizing campaigns
of the '60s, '70s,
and '80s all failed.
Silicon Valley became the
laboratory and the blueprint
for a lean American capitalism.
Apple never produced the good
life for its line workers
like General Motors did.
And the story of flexibility
in Silicon Valley
is not just the insecurity
of the workers in the bottom,
but of course, the
success of workers
at the top, of the
venture capitalists that
moved from startup to startup,
of software engineers who
hopped from project to project,
of consultants designing
strategies and
organizational structures
to maximize profits
and flexibility.
And that's a story that
we're more familiar with.
But underneath that
world were layers
of formal and informal
workers, of migrants.
These migrants worked in
large assembly factories,
small Quonset huts, and
even in their own kitchens,
making the electronics
that made those venture
capitalists wealthy.
And even though they
are usually left out
of the story of Silicon Valley,
they are essential to its rise.
From top to bottom,
Silicon Valley
defines a new universal
model of business,
even as its own industry,
electronics, and then software,
were unique.
And it's interesting what's
hidden by the stories we tell
as well as the graphs.
This is a graph that
everybody here knows.
It's a graph of
Moore's law, which
becomes, with the
rise of electronics,
the new time signature
of capitalism.
Twice as many
transistors crammed
on chips every 18 months--
look at it.
It's so smooth.
It's so logarithmic.
This pace of miniaturization
is astounding.
It also has other consequences.
It's impossible for
firms to earn much money
before they have to move on
to the next kind of chip.
And this punishing
cycle made electronics
a very different
kind of industry
than in, for
instance, aerospace,
where the same
machines could be used
for year after year on
the same kinds of bodies,
or even in cars.
So work couldn't be as
mechanized as in an earlier
economy.
It had to be more flexible.
And this flexibility
depended on people,
especially cheap people,
especially disposable workers.
And so the flexibility of
this production of Moore's law
just was not from
engineering wizardry
as much as it was from workers.
So as we-- this is one part
of one chapter in the book.
And the first part
of the chapter
is about that world of
consultants and business
leaders, the story
of Steve Jobs,
the story of McKinsey
remaking Silicon Valley.
It's a story that you can
see in this slide here,
the story of the corporation
from top to bottom,
of consultants, and temps,
and subcontracted workers,
undocumented workers.
But today I want to talk about
the people at the very bottom
as this new kind of
leading sector emerges.
And if we think about
the word "temp"--
and this book is going to annoy
lots of social scientists.
Because they're like, oh, that
just means office workers.
Like, well, yeah,
but really, it's
a more expansive
category of flexibility.
And this kind of
woman is probably
the woman you imagine coming
out of the post-war who
may work as an office
temp, a white woman,
slender and beautiful.
She's really a housewife,
but really, she
goes, sometimes, to work.
This is certainly
the story that's
told by people like
Elmer Winter who
started Manpower Incorporated,
that this is all discretionary.
This kind of work is a choice
for middle-class white women.
But this is not
the kind of woman
I want you to think
about as we are
exploring this hidden
history of Silicon Valley.
I want you to think
of faces like this.
I want you to think of
hands like this, women
who need to work, and of
course, the many people
whose faces we don't have
pictures of, who remained
undocumented even as their work
made Silicon Valley possible.
Every year after 1965,
the INS apprehended
more, what they called, illegal
aliens in industry and service
than in agriculture.
In fact, these
undocumented workers
were foundational to the
rise of Silicon Valley.
Now this is perhaps ironic
that workers matter so much
in Silicon Valley.
Because of course, if
we imagine a place that
would be automated, that would
be this future kind of world,
it would be electronics.
Apple, for instance-- and I can
say this because I'm at Google,
not Apple, which I understand
you guys are all excited
about--
Apple, that iconic Silicon
Valley firm, bragged, in 1984,
that the factory for its
new computer, something
called the Macintosh,
would be the most automated
in the world.
And everywhere, they
celebrated this,
a machine that builds machines.
It's amazing.
It's highly automated.
It's the future.
It's robots.
It's everything we imagined
about the world to come.
And yet Apple's factory,
like all other electronics
factories, was
shockingly old-fashioned.
It had some robots
on the line there.
But to understand the
electronics industry
is very, very simple.
Every time someone says "robot,"
simply picture, instead,
a migrant woman of color.
Instead of self-aware
robots, workers--
nearly all women and
mostly immigrant--
hunched over tables
with magnifying glasses
assembling parts.
In the entire world, in
1986, only two industries
accounted, according to that
left-wing propaganda instrument
"McKinsey Quarterly," for 80%
of installed robots in aerospace
and automaking.
And these workplaces of--
these are all pictures of
the first Macintosh plants.
These workplaces were
organized in accordance
with new lean
manufacturing principles.
Historians often talk
about the NUMMI factory,
that collaboration between
General Motors and Toyota,
where today, of course,
Tesla has its own factory.
That was across the street
from the first Macintosh
plant in Fremont, California.
They were both of the same
moment, the same ideas
of flexible production,
of pushing things out
into the supply chain.
But of course, with
auto manufacturing,
that supply chain
was very visible.
The supply chains of these
places were instead--
these electronics
firms were more hidden.
Instead of robots,
Silicon Valley
relied upon a
transient workforce.
If they were white and
native-born, they were temps.
If they weren't, then
they were the laborers
who worked by the
day or by the piece.
Tech firms outsourced
labor to temp agencies,
subcontracted sweatshops and
overseas factories eventually.
So let's tell the story of this.
Let's tell the story
of John Senko, who,
in 1984, was an 18-year veteran
of the INS, the forerunner
of today's ICE.
And it opens its first
office in San Jose
and begins to oversee
the immigration
issues in Silicon Valley.
The INS believed
that as much as 25%
of the Silicon Valley
workforce, about 200,000 people,
was undocumented.
Sanko's task was simple,
and yet impossible--
eliminate illegal labor
in Silicon Valley.
The office had only
four investigators
and was chronically
under-resourced.
Senko said, quote, "It's
difficult to make people
realize, because the nature of
the industry, illegal aliens
are working here.
It's hard because
high technology
is sophisticated industry.
And it was easy to believe
that no part of the production
was unskilled."
Behind graphs of this
world, the people
were-- there were people
who were not officially
part of that workforce.
Behind graphs of
growth were workers
like a woman named Fermina--
whose name actually
wasn't Fermina.
It's a fake name I
used in the book--
whose names aren't as
actually well-known
as IBM PC or Apple II.
In 1982, Fermina had worked
at an electronics assembly
plant in Tijuana where she
had earned $0.65 an hour,
quote, "soldering gold
filaments to nodes
neatly marked on
printed circuits"
for about three years.
She peered, hour after hour,
through her microscope,
bonding semiconductors.
Then the peso
destabilized, and Fermina
crossed the border to stay with
relatives and look for work.
Looking in the newspaper,
she called a number
where she could even
inquire about jobs
she had once left behind.
She could even do it in Spanish.
She felt very welcomed
in her new country.
And she found her own job
bonding semiconductors.
But this time, it was in an
assembly plant that made parts
for personal computers.
Instead of $0.65 an
hour, she now got $5.
In the plant,
hundreds of Mexicans
worked alongside
Fermina, many of them
undocumented just like her.
For Fermina, it was
a great-paying job.
And for the firm, it was
a great-paying, very cheap
employee.
For Fermina and people like
her, it enabled great profits.
In 1983, this factory was
the fourth-largest supplier
of personal computers
in the United States
with sales of $75 million
and profits of $13 million.
So that sounds good.
It seems like a
win-win situation.
But you see, her life was,
in fact, quite insecure.
Because when the INS raid came
through in November of 1984,
Fermina hid in a supply
closet, terrified.
Fermina escaped.
But 50 of her coworkers,
nearly all Mexican women,
were put in vans
for deportation.
Quote, "I came to this
country to work hard,
but now I live torn
between duty and shame."
Fermina was not alone.
Other high-profile INS raids
found firms that employed,
on average, about half of their
assembly workforces illegally.
Scholars estimate that about
100,000 Hispanic women, largely
undocumented, worked
in electronics
just in Southern California.
At the other end, consider the
life of the temp Dennis Hayes.
A world-- just recently, the
Ampex sign was taken down.
And I, for one,
was very surprised
to not hear this history
told about the history
of that iconic
Silicon Valley firm.
But in the story
of Dennis Hayes,
we can see the story
of the interconnection
between the white
native-born workforce
and this other hidden
world of subcontracting.
Dennis Hayes had dropped out of
his PhD program in sociology.
And he came to California
to start temping in 1980.
And he may have
hating temping, but he
noticed that he didn't have
the worst job in the valley.
Hayes noticed that
this futuristic economy
rested on a very old idea--
give the dirty,
dangerous work to people
who had no alternative.
Hayes temped at
Ampex, which was then
a leading audio
electronics firm.
And he worked on the floor
of the assembly room,
but he didn't put
anything together.
In that room was, like
most assembly rooms
in Silicon Valley, nearly all
women, mostly women of color.
And they put the
parts together there
with tools that were ancient,
much older than transistors,
much older than screwdrivers,
even older than the axe.
They used their fingernails.
These women would
grow two or three
strategically long
fingernails on each hand
so they could move the
components onto the circuit
boards.
Ampex was not unique.
This all came through this
world of work dependant
on fingernails and
not automation.
Now what did Dennis Hayes do
there if he did not actually
put things together?
Well, his job was to deliver
and pick up components
from subcontractors,
the metal shops.
High-end audio was made possible
by low-end subcontracting.
And in this regard,
it was not just
about finding cheap worker, or
cheap suppliers, or vendors,
but subcontracting
out toxic work
to places and people that were
not part of OSHA regulations.
So Hayes would drive
to a "dirt floor"
Quonset hut in Santa Clara,
inside of which were "Hispanic"
workers in rubber boot--
when I go like this,
it means I'm quoting,
because I'm a historian, OK--
and "rubber boots,
gloves, and apron"
and without respiratory masks.
The front and back doors of
these Quonset huts were open.
Some passively turning
fans were in the ceiling.
But otherwise, there
was no ventilation.
The workers moved
around quickly,
stoking fires beneath
vats of chemicals-- fires,
vats, boiling chemicals
climbing up and down
the jerry-built platforms
which gave access to the vats.
Some of the vats boiled.
Others, untouched by the
fires, yielded the smoke
of the chemical reaction.
He was there to drop off
chassis panels, nuts, and screws
made in Ampex's factory.
And these subcontracted workers
dipped the unfinished alloys
in their vats.
Hayes was only there
for minutes at a time,
but he wrote that the
foul, metallic odors,
"made me want to
hold my breath."
Hayes never spoke to
the workers there,
only to the boss, who
spoke to him in English
while commanding the
workers in Spanish.
So the point of this
system of production
was not just to find cheaper,
but to avoid legal action.
This is tort-liable
work outsourced
to a network of employees
to act as intermediaries.
No official employee of
Ampex delivered or picked up
the panels, nuts, and screws.
So no official employee
of Ampex could ever
really know the
conditions under which
this chemistry took place.
If there was a legal
problem with one
of these vat-filled
Quonset huts,
it would have been easy
to disappear into just
another anonymous Quonset hut.
And so the clean rooms
of high technology
are built atop a foundation of
very dirty, very toxic Quonset
huts.
And of course, today,
Santa Clara County
has more EPA Superfund
sites than any other county
in the United States.
At the very bottom of
this system of electronics
manufacture was not the small
factory or the Quonset hut,
but kitchens.
Investigators found that
somewhere between 10% and 30%
of electronics firms
subcontracted to what they
called, quote, "homeworkers."
Like garment workers taking
in sewing in the 1880s,
electronics workers
could assemble parts
in their kitchens--
a mother and her
children gathered
around a kitchen table,
assembling components
for $0.07 apiece.
These little shops put
together the boards
that went to the big companies.
A California Labor inspector
turned a blind eye, saying,
quote, "A Mexican or
Vietnamese can take home
1,000 coils for
wiring one evening,
and put every close neighbor
and family member to work,
and return, the next
day, to the plant.
It's not even worth our
time trying to wipe it out.
When there are people
eager to work for pennies,
you can expect that kind of
thing to happen," end quote.
It was their fault for being
"eager" to work for pennies.
While the image of the
Silicon Valley was futuristic,
its methods were more that
of 19th century tenements.
These homeworkers offered
firms a cheap labor force.
But the real appeal was,
of course, flexibility.
Chip processing fluctuated.
Like cars, computer demand
varied through the year,
both for consumers--
holidays, the new school year--
and for changes in
technology-- ah,
the new cycle of chips, the
tick-tock, as we call it today.
And as demand went up
and down, these firms
had no obligation to
their homeworkers.
So these kitchens
and Quonset huts
would open and close as needed.
Now the exact number,
how many firms,
how many chips is hard
to point down exactly,
because itself was a subterfuge.
Behind the big,
expensive plants were
vast networks of other workers.
Tellingly, more firms in
the early 1980s at least,
in various business
surveys subcontracted
to exactly these
kinds of homeworkers
than offshore plants.
Anyhow, what did the
INS do about this?
This is-- as you imagine,
there's not many pictures.
But this is a picture of a
binder, Volume 8, entitled
"Illegal Aliens,"
from the INS library
just to give you a sense of
what that world looks like.
The INS encouraged
the large companies
to cooperate by offering them
lenience for giving up their,
quote, "illegal aliens."
At Circuit Assembly
Corporation in San Jose,
the INS asked for names of its
non-citizen, non-documented
employees.
Of the 250 names, the
company thought that, quote,
"20 or 30 of them could
be using forged papers."
The actual number was
187, 187 out of 250.
And the company,
because it cooperated,
received no penalties, no
sanctions, and according
to Senko, simply replaced
those 187 with other workers
while those workers were,
themselves, deported.
When Senko came to
San Jose in 1984,
he raided not just
workplaces, but neighborhoods.
In Menlo Park,
just near Stanford,
INS agents blocked the streets,
removing Hispanic males
from cars and from
homes, checking them
for proof of citizenship.
In Santa Cruz, the INS went door
to door checking citizenship.
Senko and the INS
agents believed
they did not need warrants
to name names ahead of time.
Now of course, local
governments pushed back.
The San Jose
government push back
against the INS in
the name of defending,
quote, "Chicano citizens"
against harassment,
passing a resolution
against this, quote,
"unwarranted disruption of
the business community."
In December 1985, San Francisco
declares itself a sanctuary
city and directs its
police and officials not
to assist the INS in finding
law-abiding but undocumented
migrants.
So what happens then?
Does all this end?
No.
The INS enforcement
becomes more selective,
which actually enables
Silicon Valley corporations
to have even more power over
their undocumented workforce.
Businesses could selectively
check Green Cards
against an INS database.
If workers began to
organize or push back
in any way against their
bosses, they could be deported.
The spokesperson for the
International Association
of Machinists explained
that when everyone
tried to organize, the
company threatened to have
anyone in the union deported.
What about John Senko?
Let's not forget
about his travails,
his troubles as an INS
agent here in San Jose.
Well, for him, it was the
worst three years of his life.
He came to believe if he
was actually successful
in deporting undocumented
workers from Silicon Valley,
we'd have a "revolution."
He preferred, he said,
businesses to cooperate rather
than to have them raided.
But that missed the point.
The low cost of the undocumented
as well as their willingness,
their need to work in illegal
conditions, in toxic situations
made them too valuable, too
necessary to the Silicon Valley
economy.
This economy, former INS
head told a newspaper
around that time, was built
on the assumption or reality
of a heavy influx
of illegal labor.
This former head of the
INS was not just referring
to the electronics industry,
but the entire economy
of the American West.
This new American
economy that was
looked to by the rest of
America as the future,
as the most influential,
as the most successful
was an economy that was built
on the backs of people who
had few rights, built on
the backs of those excluded,
built on the backs of those
who were so hard-pressed,
they put their children to
work in their own kitchens.
By the end of the 1980s,
these kinds of operations
left the Bay Area, leaving
behind the people who
had made this new accumulation
of wealth possible,
and of course, the country's
largest Superfund sites.
This is a picture
of two people that
replaced-- that trained their
own replacements in Singapore
before Apple moved overseas.
Look how happy they are.
They're so proud.
Now why am I telling
you this story?
I'm telling you a story of the
1980s, which, at this point,
is a long time ago.
And I'm not telling
you the story
of the people who are above
this, the world of consultants,
and temps, and all those
independent contractors.
These people are important
too, to this story.
But I'm telling you this
story today, this history
because it's similar to how we
are talking about the future
now.
Just as Apple talked about
a world of automation
and delivered a world
of exploitation,
so too we hear the
same kind of language
obscuring a certain
kind of reality today.
The language of
robots and AI still
do this cultural
and linguistic work
of erasing the
present-day workforce,
both visible and invisible.
These workers are transitionary.
These workers are disposable.
The low-paid contingent
workers of Silicon Valley
do not count, because some day
they will be replaced by an AI,
or so we hear.
It's not a coincidence that
these transitional workers
look nothing like
the engineers that
are the face of Silicon Valley.
The plight of Uber
drivers doesn't really
matter as its CEO tells us.
And I'm pretty sure
mispronouncing it
when I call him Travis Colonic.
Because of source, someday,
narrow machine-learning AI
will take it over.
These people are a transition
to a better world to come,
and it doesn't matter
how they suffer.
But yet somehow this
future never comes to them.
This ever-receding future
seems to legitimate
a very real, very unequal,
seemingly unending present.
So as we think about
the future, as we-- oh,
there we are, the rotten apple.
As we think about
the future, we have
to ask, again and again,
the same question--
who counts?
Who deserves, if not guaranteed
work, at least secure lives?
Who matters?
We must, as we think
about this, also not
forget that even for those
post-war white men, those men
who got pensions and
defined benefits,
men who had the good paychecks,
working on the assembly line,
or in a mine, or even in
an office, in a factory
was dehumanizing,
sometimes backbreaking,
but most often,
soul-breaking work.
Whatever the wages and
benefits, humans should not
do the work of robots.
So it's not simply that we
should give up on automation,
we should give up on
robotics, we should give up
on the future,
but that we should
think about the future
cognizantly of how
the past has used the
future to erase the present.
We can't turn back the clock
to a world that was never
as great as we imagined
it was, to an America
that was never as wonderful
as we often hear it was.
But progress does not
require insecurity.
Just as the post-war
period managed
to make industrialization
benefit some industrial workers
to give some people
this level of security,
we need to create new norms,
institutions, and policies
to make digitization
benefit everyone today.
It's important, as we make
choices going into this world,
whether conservative or
liberal, that this world
of independent work, this
world of automation is coming
and that we need to remember
that we have choices about how
it will play out, that
the distribution of wealth
and productivity is not
just an economic reality,
but a political choice.
So just as the
industrial economy
offered inequality and
growth for 100 years
before it produced the,
quote, "good life," so,
too, will the digital economy.
And we need to understand that
this flexible workforce can,
depending on the
choices that we make,
be the liberation from wage
work that Americans have
so long yearn for,
or to be immiserated,
to be damned to insecure
life in an unequal society.
And as we choose
this world before us,
we should not make the
mistakes of the past,
creating a more
inclusive capitalism that
accounts for everybody.
Insecurity is not
the inevitable cost,
nor does progress require
treating people like machines.
Only by understanding
that fact can
we make capitalism work
for us, not work us over.
Thank you so much.
Happy to be here today.
[APPLAUSE]
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So it sounds like
one of the primary reasons
that undocumented workers
were able to be exploited
was because they
were undocumented.
How do you feel
about open borders?
LOUIS HYMAN: Yeah, I'm
actually very much--
so in the book, I
take account of all
these different approaches.
So one of the approaches
people often say
is, well, we should
have sanctions, right,
against employers.
If you hire someone
who's undocumented,
we should sanction the employer.
And in fact, in 1970,
the state of California,
under Governor Ronald
Reagan, a former movie actor,
passes a law to do this.
And in fact, that following
month after it was passed,
the department responsible for
it lost 79 out of 80 employees,
leaving one person to enforce
the law in the whole state.
That law was actually
never enforced ever.
And again and again, there
is an appeal to this idea
that we can simply
solve this problem
of excluding and
exploiting people
by sanctioning employers.
And it's never happened ever.
There's too much pressure
on the other hand
for large corporations.
So I think we do need
to have open borders.
We need to make sure--
at least we need to make
sure that people who are here
are protected under the same
kinds of laws and rights
as people who are
citizens of this country.
Did I bum everybody out?
AUDIENCE: So I have a question.
LOUIS HYMAN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So if robots are
going to make everything, what
about basic income for
everybody else so that if I
own the robot, I'll send it
to work, and I can relax.
LOUIS HYMAN: Sure.
This is often like, what
about the basic income?
So in the future, people
will be worthless.
In the future, all
that will matter
will be programmers, and other
technologists, and engineers.
And I talk about, this is
often something I hear.
Like, oh, I'm the only
one that's worthwhile.
Well, I think that there
are actually lots of things
that people do that are
worthwhile besides computer
programming.
And I think as we
look to the future--
as I think, actually,
you guys all
agree, as we look
to the future--
we should be thinking about
how we can use technology
to liberate us, do work
that is more human.
And just as mechanical
thresher meant
that we didn't have to all
go in and reap the harvest,
we can use automation
to liberate us
from tedium, from paperwork.
And this is something
we have to take account
of as we think about the future,
how work can become more human.
We can become caring, and
curious, and creative together.
And the basic
income is certainly
one approach to do this.
It's certainly a very
liberal approach.
It's approach that
has a lot of appeal.
But it also is in contrast to
a lot of the political values
that Americans have.
So another approach, a
more conservative approach,
would simply be,
do something that
is modeled on the 401(k), where,
as you move from job to job,
you are able to take your
retirement, and health care,
and other kinds of
benefits with you.
I think what's important here is
not the specific policy that we
use to address this new
independent workforce, or even
automation.
It's that we need to
make sure that we're not
just nostalgic for
the past and try
to return to this old
world, whether you're
a Republican or a Democrat.
I also think that as we think
about solutions to this,
we need to acknowledge that
the automation has never
fully replaced the
need for people,
and that people will
always be of value.
AUDIENCE: One sense I got from
this talk was that automation--
you said Apple kept claiming
that they were going to do
fully automated factories.
But it seems like that will not
happen, that the temp work will
just change hands, in this
case, from Silicon Valley
to Singapore, and
then from Singapore
maybe to somewhere else.
Is that a conclusion
that you have come to?
Or do you think that
we will eventually
reach a point that automation
does actually happen?
LOUIS HYMAN: Well,
automation has certainly
already happened in the sense of
increasing productivity, right?
I mean, if you think about
things like agriculture--
the best analog is not--
in the AI world of
tomorrow, is not--
industry, it's agriculture.
So that less than
2% of the workforce
now feeds all the rest of us.
And those people are able
to do other kinds of things.
The thing I think--
the rhetorical value--
the rhetorical consequent
of automation and
robotics is imagining
a future in which the
present is erased, right,
and that some
people are left out
of this new economy, or
the contemporary economy,
and treated badly.
And that's the kind
of thing that I'm
trying to push back against,
I think, in this history.
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
and it just seems
like when one source,
when one person to erase
has been erased, they'll
just move onto the next one
is what I mean.
LOUIS HYMAN: Yeah,
it's a problem--
AUDIENCE: It just
seems like it's
going to keep going that
way, that we're never
going to actually get
that perfect automation.
We'll just find another group.
LOUIS HYMAN: Well, that
would be unfortunate.
I'd like to think that we'd
be able to make progress
in not just playing
whack-a-mole where we're
the moles that get whacked
all around the world because
of automation.
I do think automation--
there's a lot of ways
in which narrow AI has
a lot of opportunities
here, as I'm sure all of you
can talk to me more about
than I can talk to you about.
And machine learning
is exciting.
But I do think it's going
to be relatively constrained
and not take over
every aspect of life.
AUDIENCE: Of course
I don't think
it's going to take over
every aspect right now.
I'm just probably
badly extrapolating
from the story shown
in this talk so far.
LOUIS HYMAN: Well, I think
that's also a good point.
So the question
is, fundamentally,
can things get better?
Is that what you're saying?
And I think one of
the things that we
can learn from the
history of capitalism
is that it can be
more inclusive.
I think things in our
economy is more inclusive
than it was 40 years ago.
It's certainly more inclusive
than it was 400 years ago.
And we can change the
foundations of capitalism
as we want.
So in 1850, 55% of
the GDP of America
was based on enslaved people
or the products they produced.
And yet 10, 15 years-- and
15 years later, it's not.
And so we can remoor
the foundation.
For me, this is a
tremendous opportunity
to think about, well, how
do we remake capitalism
so that it works for
more people, you know?
And I think that's something
we need to consider as we--
whether we want automation
to make a few people rich,
or whether we want it to just--
or to liberate the rest of us.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, and I
guess my point is not
that things don't get better.
It's more, how
long can we keep--
can this game keep
being played for?
Because so far,
at least for now,
it seems like that's
what we're doing.
We're just going to
keep playing this game.
LOUIS HYMAN: Well, I
think we have a choice
about playing the game.
And I think that's a
great point though.
That's a great point.
AUDIENCE: So you mentioned that
automation cannot completely
replace people.
So I'm curious to hear your
perspective about a scenario
where automation does
replace people entirely,
let's say if you
have machines that
are as smart, and
as intelligent,
and creative as humans.
LOUIS HYMAN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: At that point--
I mean, from your perspective,
what do you think?
LOUIS HYMAN: What would happen?
So in that scenario?
AUDIENCE: How would that
change society as we know it?
LOUIS HYMAN: Well,
I mean, I think
people are valuable not just
because they're smart, right?
So people are valuable
insofar as they
can care for one
another, insofar
as they can create
for one another.
So if you're just
talking about a future
where you're like a "Westworld"
general AI scenario where
the robots are as smart as us--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so imagine--
LOUIS HYMAN: "Terminator?"
AUDIENCE: --an AI
scenario, I which may not
be that close as we think.
But let's say, if that happens,
from your perspective--
I'm just curious.
LOUIS HYMAN: Yeah, no,
I mean, I would be--
it would fall-- like
most science fiction,
it would fall into
the 100% dystopian
and scary or 100% utopian
and kind of boring, right?
We would just sit around just
eating ice cream all day,
which is boring but
kind of wonderful.
My suspicion is it's
going to be more
like the mechanical thresher
in that technologies
will accelerate productivity.
They will displace
segments of the workforce.
And we'll have to
figure out what to do
with the rest of the people.
So coming out of this
agricultural revolution,
we had to really tool up the
way we educated our people.
So this is the moment when
people become literate,
when they begin to go to
school in the 1920s and '30s.
And that kind of
industrial education
worked well for
an industrial age.
And we found other
uses for them.
So I think the
trick is, nowadays,
our educational system is
not built to teach people
how to learn how to learn.
It's built to
teach them to obey.
And we need to have an
educational system that
does encourage curiosity and
creativity for the new kind
of economy to come.
If this happens, I don't think
history will matter at all.
Because that kind of
world of general AI
will be just something
that I probably imagine
you or I can't
fully think about.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so I know
the focus of your talk
was primarily on
the past and how
we should use it to
frame the way that we
think about the present and
how we want to mold the future.
It was more focused on
generalities rather than
specific public policy.
You mentioned corporate
sanctions as an idea
that we shouldn't try.
But surely there must
be public policies
that you think we should be
advocating for, you know,
either internally, as
members of a corporation,
or as citizens
who vote, in order
to shape the future that
would be more pleasant.
What are some of those policies?
LOUIS HYMAN: Some
of those policies
are laid in this
delightful book,
available for sale in
the back of the room.
AUDIENCE: I've
already bought mine.
Everyone else
should do the same.
LOUIS HYMAN: They make wonderful
doorstops, or kindling,
depending on your proclivities.
So I think that there are lots
of policies that one could go.
In the book, I lay out
both very conservative ones
so you can talk about it
with your Republican friends.
You can also talk about it
with your liberal friends.
I think what's important
is that we choose to make--
to recognize what's
happening, that this is--
that half of people
under 34 are working
in this freelance economy,
right, in this gig economy,
in this temp economy, and
that this reality is not
being talked about, right?
We are treating
it as, this is not
"real work" this
is not "real job."
Well, this is where
people are, right?
And I think that this
book is trying to put
that in a longer perspective.
So people talk about it as
if it's Uber, and the apps,
and the phones, and
stuff like that.
Well, this has been
going on for a long time.
And we need to
understand that it's
choices we're making about
big corporations, how
they treat the people
who work for them
in a temporary fashion.
Large tech firms often
have numbers of contractors
and other kinds
of subcontractors.
What is the relationship
between them and the, quote,
"real employees?"
How do we even value companies
like that if we look at them?
You know, one of the reasons
we value a company so much is
how low their headcount is.
The fewer employees, the better.
So how do we think
about valuation
if they want to embed not
just money, but our values?
So this is an
important question.
AUDIENCE: So there's no
one specific public policy
you want to get
up on your soapbox
and advocate for more
than a [INAUDIBLE]??
LOUIS HYMAN: There's
no silver bullet.
There's no, like,
let's get basic income,
and then everything will be OK.
Or let's put employer
sanctions in place,
and then everything
will be OK, right?
If there were a simple answer,
we already would have done it.
And I think what
we need to do is
have a larger, more
expansive conversation that
talks about the big question
of how do we create security
in a world where work
is more insecure.
And maybe we decouple, in
many different possible ways,
depending on our
political consensus, how
that security may no longer
relate to the job, right,
and split those things apart.
So one of the things I
think a lot about is,
how is the job like
marriage, right?
How is work like
Very few people these days
are getting married, right?
And yet we're still trying
to rebuild our social system,
or our social norms, addressing
this problem of, what happens
to children coming out of--
they're are born out
of marriages, right?
And this is the norm now.
That's happening.
We have to acknowledge that.
I mean, we don't-- we want
those kids to grow up well.
We want this to be
the world that we--
that people are treated well in.
Similarly for work, the norm--
a few very privileged people
are allowed to have secure jobs.
Like, I have a lot of security.
I'm a tenured professor
at a school, right?
So I am part of this old world.
70% of professors are
adjuncts, you know?
They make $2,000
to $3,000 a course.
Their lives are immiserating.
And it's important that people
like me say that's not OK.
Or how do we take this
kind of flexibility
and create security for them?
And similarly, for those who
are in positions where they have
security in their lives to
speak for these other people
that don't have
as much security--
and I think that's
just being humane.
It was a good question though.
Thank you so much.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: My question is
a little bit off-topic.
But you mentioned that post-war,
with traditional industries,
the workers would have unions.
But for us, software
engineers, I
don't think we have a union
or any kind of those things.
Do think, because of the nature
of the job, it's not necessary?
Or it is just a problem
that we just ignore?
LOUIS HYMAN: Do you
want to have a union?
AUDIENCE: Software engineers?
LOUIS HYMAN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I don't know.
That's why I'm asking.
LOUIS HYMAN: Yeah, I
mean, I think it depends.
You need a union if
you feel like you--
I mean, for me,
generally, it's like,
you need a union if you feel
like you don't have agency
in how you control your own
work process and your own life,
and you feel like
you're being mistreated.
I suspect you feel like
you're worked a lot at Google,
but you're not
mistreated exactly.
You know, I think that's
very different than if you're
in a dead-end job where the
boss kind of dictates to you,
and you feel like
you have no control.
Historically, that's only--
so I would worry less about--
I don't worry as much
about software engineers
unless I know them and
they're friends of mine,
that I work with them
on a personal level.
But as a class of workers,
I'm not as worried about them
as I am about janitors,
or GrubHub delivery
people, or retail workers.
You know, in the coming years--
the gentleman, earlier, was
asking about automation.
I kind of don't
believe in the world
of general AI, and "Westworld,"
and stuff like that.
But I do think retail workers
will all lose their jobs
in the next 15 years.
This is where most
people work, and they're
going to lose their employment.
Now software engineers, you guys
have a lot to worry about too,
right?
I mean there's a lot
of contract work.
You know, at Google, you're
kind of at the Cornell,
or the Harvard, or whatever,
or Dartmouth of software,
so you're not as worried.
But a lot of people in
software engineering
have very tenuous, precarious
jobs as software engineers.
And there's a lot of
things coming down
the pipeline that seem like
it could automate software
engineering as well.
But I think the trick is
that software engineering,
as you guys literally all--
every single one of you
knows better than I do,
is not just coding, but
being creative, right,
thinking analytically
about algorithms.
And I don't think
a computer can do
that as well as a human being.
AUDIENCE: Well, I'm not
mostly worried about myself.
As you mentioned, there's a
lot of, like, contract coders,
or freelancers, which,
in general, are not
protected by any kind of
unions or laws, anything.
LOUIS HYMAN: When people are
highly skilled and in demand,
they don't need
unions as much, right?
So I think that
programmers, as long
as they are part of-- they
deliver lots of value,
they're high-skilled,
they're not
totally interchangeable--
despite what
I read in Quora, I don't
think that programmers
are interchangeable.
And I think that there's
a lot of opportunity
for people to work
remotely and be anywhere.
One of the exciting things
about this economy is that--
in the book, I write how
what's different about today
is not AI.
AI, narrow AI, is just
another way in which
tools become more productive.
What's different is we may no
longer need the corporation
to access those tools,
that you can sell globally,
you can work globally,
you can consume globally.
And that the corporation
might no longer
be necessary in capitalism
is a shocking transformation.
So I think that that's what you
guys should be thinking about.
How do we work in flexible teams
assembling production together?
And so do you need a union?
I think that's only
for you to decide.
But I think unions are
really necessary when
people don't have power unless
they work together Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]